Music
??????????
it's Sammy
Mario RPG!
Ha ha ha!
Mom mommy!
We are playing on the normal mode!
Ha ha ha!
We play on the normal mode!
Wow!
Ha ha ha!
Oh look at that! It's the beach!
Ha ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha!
Wow that is fun!
Ah
Hahaha
Yes, thank you
Okay, let's play look at these guys whoa are these the cool I can dodge these fuck yeah
okay can't dodge these whoa
pack head up in you win the coins cheap
ah
they're so broke wait where is she
oh she's stuck up there it's a beach beach you come back
don't let brows bowser bruise you Mario prepare yourself for the great beyond
let's go oh Mario let me try this again let me try this again okay special attack
come down stomp unfolds press a just before it fits okay I'm gonna try it
well
chain
What a joke, what's the muscle into it?
Ugh, my timing's so bad guys, I did it, I blocked, oh, hi, the chain, attack the chain,
I got it, I got it Peach, shut the fuck up, oh man, I'll learn what timing is in like 10 seconds,
oh wait, it worked, what was that sound, no, no, it's a chain reaction, it's a chain
dill here, I'm holding on by the skin of your teeth, whatever you do, don't let go, yeah,
coming Mario, hi Mario, hi, this should finish you,
oh, it's slower, oh he's crying, wow, did you think I was just gonna give her to you,
you're always in my way, this is it, I'm gonna take you out Mario, oh god, foiled again,
oh he's still crying, oh, oh Mario, you had me so worried, let's get out of here,
Mario, the hook castle's shaking, oh, it's a star, and a sword, with eyes, uh oh,
oh, well, rip, Bowser's castle, you're our star Mercy, you're my star Senpai, Super Mario,
ah, PG, what, Mario's pad, oh, when did he get a pipe for a chimney, I don't know what
sounds like, so, hey Mario, lots of people use something called door to go in and out
of their houses, anyway, I came by to pick up Princess Peach since she's bit late, yep,
oh, look, oh, he went to bed, he went to bed, wake up, oh, I have to jump, okay,
I wanna hit the cuckoo clock, okay, maybe not, look, nothing is stored,
oh, hey, I thought the princess was here with you, Mario, so where is she, Mario,
what's with the silent treatment, you're not telling me something, it's Bowser again,
isn't it, oh no, here we go again, what am I doing, some pies, Mario, would you please
bring her back like you always do, Mario, I forgot something important, if you get knocked
out, you'll wake up at the last place you saved, guess what, on this adventure, you'll save automatically,
wherever you go between areas, I'll save you all the time, so the worst comes to worst, you won't
lose too much progress, am I right, you can also hop in this thing to save, it's like the good old days,
we use them however you like, they're great for taking a break from your adventure,
that's everything important I can think of, now get yourself to Bowser's, keep, no, Bowser's keep,
right, the good old days, I wanna go back up, wait, Mario's house, I labeled my house,
come on, let me jump, let me jump, let me jump, let me jump, jump, jump, jump, jump, jump, jump, no,
I actually have the original Mario RPG, but I found out it's the Japanese version, so I'm kind of,
you know, out of luck,
he labeled his house, but does he have a street address, it's Mario 10, Mario street, Mario
wait, what's the kingdom called again,
mushroom kingdom, right, halt, who goes there, a trespasser, this castle now belongs to us, the smithy
gang, we have big plans and this is the first step in them, if it weren't for your nosy characters
like you would practically own this world, so let's see you deal with this
oh
I can't believe Mario communicates and jumps, that jump was why I order
it
this is Mario language, right, oh,
where did I run off to, did I run outside again, like an idiot, yeah I did, I ran outside like
an idiot, so what do I do now, that I can't go there, can I move my thing,
okay I can't go there, so I have to go here, right, I have to go in my home, right,
held, you're back so soon, did you forget something, no what happened then,
wait, how did you walk on air Mario, the bridge to Bowser's keep is out now, just wonderful,
you must inform the Chancellor of the Mushroom Kingdom at once, let's go Mario
okay
oops excuse me, oh that bump on your head reduced your HP level, one of the Mushroom Kingdom's
famous item, I'm gonna perk you right up, got a mushroom, whenever you want to use an item to get
some help, HP back, X, eating a mushroom can give you a boost whenever you're feeling tired,
I should do that right now, oh now why did I rush back, I had something to tell you,
ah I remember, I didn't know I knew that mushroom way is swarming with monsters,
it has barely made it back here in one piece, Mario please do something,
grass that can help, you know about action commands, no let's learn about this,
let's learn about this together, senpai,
okay allow me to explain,
first we'll enter a battle, timing is important in battles, I'll show you what I mean,
first press A, hold it, now hit A as the attack hits, good timing, when successful your damage
just increases, press A with perfect timing and your attack will damage the surrounding enemies too,
hit A as enemy attacks too, good timing, if your timing is perfect you take no damage,
but action commands won't save you from attacks that hit your whole party,
now try a special move by pressing Y,
Y, jump,
press A here, good timing, depending on the moves sometimes you'll have to do more than just
press a button, so keep an eye out for that, by the way each time you nail an action command
this action gauge fills up a little, when the action gauge reaches 100%
then your enemy better watch out, so look forward to that,
more successful action commands you do the higher this number will go,
if you can do two or more times in a row some boss will start to kick in, for you Mario the
action gauge will fill faster as power for a while is up inside, I know it's a lot to take in but
never fear, you press B during your battle and select help you can go over any of this again,
you can't even see the explanation outside of battle by selecting help from the menu,
now forget it's there okay,
oh I forgot to say say something, I forgot I wanted to start start uh today by saying um
um by saying thank you for last stream's um uh super chats and and uh gifted memes,
because uh I wasn't able to to to say thank you as much uh due to due to it being a collab,
so I wanted to say thank you uh lord peanut gallery for thousand two hundred for the five
dollar super chat, thank you darlin vita pie for the two dollar super chat, and thank you uh
sunken yacht club for the five dollar super chat, thank you thank you,
okay let's go
and there you have it, nice you still, okay I need some water
and there you have it, now you stand a fighting chance against those monsters
how does it feel to be a veal or say so representative um
surprising I came in kind of being like yeah I'm such a degen I'm I'm definitely super degenerate
and then I realized all right um I'm not
I quickly understood how I vastly overestimated my power
thank you dusk and boy for the membership tier
but like I literally I literally like yeah yeah I know I read I read a lot of dojins
I know what I'm talking about and then you know the the girls come up and they are like
they say some stuff and I'm like
uh uh maybe I'm not that freaky
like I was like oh yeah I know how to do this my my my my arrow gay list is so good
and then and then for girls they open their mouths and I'm like
you know what I got I don't even hold a torch to them
like I don't even hold a torch to them and so I was like it's okay it's okay
it's okay to to be the for it to be the one that's not as as you know
exciting
haha
so I'm just um I just decided to just be me and not try to
to outdo or try to match my my gen mates I'm I'm my own I'm my own person and being the say
someone kind of has a little bit of benefits as in
as in um
I feel like some people are willing to message me a little more because maybe I I feel a little
approachable
so I'm just like yeah yeah it's fine it's fine I think I think having the title is
is actually really fun
I feel like some people are like oh it's it's not as scary or as intimidating
so uh honestly the girls are really nice they do say some out-of-pocket things but
overall I think it's not as different as other VTubers
actually I feel like we're we're quite tame or at least I'm I'm I'm tame I'm really tame
I don't even have any you know suss jokes
so yeah I think I think overall they're quite normal but sometimes when they say
things I just kind of I blush a little you know
oh but they're all lovely they're all lovely I love them all
that's right we need to tell the chancellor about peach
I'll see you over at the mushroom kingdom just in case take these with you
did you have problems with these monsters told
got three mushrooms I thought I thought you I thought you had trouble
I thought you had I thought okay maybe the toad voice this is a little hard I thought that you
have the trouble
okay I'm gonna practice I'm gonna practice Senpai
yeah
okay I suck I'm practicing
I'm gonna try to practice the timing because I'm having a little bit of trouble with it
admittedly the last time I did the timing stuff was
I think sometime last year where I was playing Super Mario Brothers
I forgot which one the Game Boy Game Boy version that's on that's on I was playing the one that's
on the Nintendo Switch online
Mario and Luigi yeah so I'm just gonna practice that Super Star Saga yeah yeah yeah that one
I'm so glad I can I can say something and then and then just be like
and then just be like it's finished like the sentence is finished by Senpai
oh okay I did it oh it should be max oh dang it oh dang it oh dang it oh dang it
oh okay
x I would no yes
yes
and then the only other Mario RPG I played was Thousand Years Door on the GameCube recently
Senpai Senpai thank you for the 20 super thank you Arcaneon
for the house fun and the best and lovely Kohai ever thank you so much
Thousand Years Door was really good my only complaint with these
Mario games so far that I played since I've only played two of them is that you know it's
pretty nice and easy until the final boss and then I want to krill myself
Any plans on playing the remake for Thousand-Year Door?
Maybe?
I feel like...
I feel like, um...
Since I've already played it, I don't have that much of an interest in playing it.
Does that make sense?
Like, since I've already played it from start to finish, and it's kind of fresh in my memory still,
it's like one of those games where I'm just like,
I don't know! I don't know!
I don't know! Since I've already played it, it's not really something in my mind.
So like, if a game is like, for example, I want to play Rhapsody,
which is one of the first RPTs I've ever played,
but I don't remember much of it, then I'm just like,
okay, okay, maybe I'll play that game because I don't remember much of it.
Wait! Yeah!
Ah!
Dodging! What is that?
Rhapsody and Musical Adventure? Yeah, that game!
I really love it!
I actually pre-ordered the Switch version because I love that one.
Ooh!
Oh, I can hit it more than once?
Oh!
Dang it!
I think jump works for these guys, right?
Yes!
Some elements are especially effective against certain monsters,
and deal big damage by taking advantage of these weaknesses.
I have a mushroom.
It's out!
Oh no, I don't have any more!
Dang it!
Okay.
Okay, look! I'm getting it, Senpai!
I'm getting it!
Oh, shit, I missed!
Yeah! Yeah, I'm getting it!
Okay, maybe the timing for the punches are not as easy.
I'll have another one.
Yeah.
Ooh!
Okay, didn't get that one.
Oh, I'm still bad!
I'm still bad.
Level up!
Mario reach level two!
Oh! Oh!
Look, look, Senpai! I can allocate my points!
Oh no!
Should I do magic?
Magic or physical?
More damage.
Physical.
Yeah, I'll go with that one.
You! My life was flashing before my eyes for a second there!
Here's a little something in return!
Ah, honey, see that?
He's still in trouble, isn't he?
Oh hey!
Oh!
Watch me!
Well, it's less damage, but that's okay.
What's this, money?
Flower items will permanently increase your max fp,
letting you use more specials.
These are super important, so don't forget them!
Bling, bling, bling, bling, bling!
Oh my, like, thingies are kind of in pain.
Maybe I have to use a different controller.
That's funny, it's like, how am I already in pain?
What?
I might have to switch controller some pie.
Oops!
That was not what I wanted.
Where was the pause button?
I had, like,
Oh!
Can I play with this one?
I think, I think I'm not used to this controller yet, Senpai.
Can I use my old controller?
Don't worry, Senpai.
The, oh, I can jump!
Okay, okay, these are nice.
These are cute.
Oh, you're looking so cute!
Don't worry, Senpai.
The accounts on my, on my, on my Switch are just the shops and guest accounts.
I'm so bad at rhythm games!
I am using the Hori pad that Senpai's gave me.
It just hurts my, um, hurts my fingers.
I don't know why.
Oh, it spins!
I'm so cute!
Oh!
Told you!
How the hell did you get up there?
Boy, that was a close call!
Here's a token of my appreciation!
My power tab!
It spooked me there!
I'm like, check my item skull high?
Oh, I can do the 10 one!
Yeah.
Got a freebie!
Okay, I almost got it.
Actually, the timing, I just stuck.
Never mind, Senpai.
Hahaha!
Weee, timing!
Oh, I got a flower!
Do you do anything special?
I'll try my best.
Why am I bad at timing?
Is this because I don't listen to music?
Is this my, is this my legacy?
Is this my, is this what happens?
How do I get you first?
Shit.
Spiky, well, jumping will be bad for Spiky.
How do I kill you?
Anyways, I'm gonna do it again.
Hey, excuse me, let me try this again.
Hey, are you looking at me?
My hammer and I don't like ya.
Mario, you better be careful, he's definitely got a mean streak!
I can just leave him?
I can just leave him!
Here you go, my hammer angry, you shouldn't have done that.
Oh, there's two of you, shit.
Use an item, Mario!
Get my health up!
I gotta get this rhythm thing down!
Huh?
The Valor?
Oh shit.
Word!
Thanks, Mario, I was running so fast I wasn't watching where I was going!
A mushroom kingdom's just ahead, we're almost there, Mario!
Hey, where did this hammer come from?
Hey, you know what this is?
This is a hammer's broke, see now you're on it!
Now it stands a chance against you when you want them with this!
You never know, it might come in handy!
Picked up a hammer!
Now that we got a hammer, any escapees?
Let's get a move on, I'll see you in the mushroom kingdom!
Any secrets about somewhere?
Meow?
Oh, where'd the cloud thing go?
Gone.
Mysterious!
Need to equip it?
X.
I don't know where to equip it.
Mushroom kingdom.
Manual? This one? Oh!
Whip and hammer!
Armor? No equipment.
Accessory? Probably none.
Hey, let me talk.
I haven't seen Princess Peach lately.
What? Bowser's got her again?
Hey, Mario, look what you're standing in.
What am I standing in?
Huh, gotcha!
Wait, what? What was I standing in?
Let me in!
Hello, creatures' houses that I will invade.
One, two, three.
Think if I practiced enough I would jump as high as you, Mario?
Sure.
Yeah!
Hey, Mario, my brother's waiting for you upstairs.
All I do is cook and clean.
How depressing.
Did he go faster?
Maybe?
He's having a good time.
Oh, wait, I can talk to this one.
Hey, did you see a crocodile around here?
He talks like a mobster wannabe.
I'm sure he's up to no good.
Hey, wait a sec, my wall's gone!
Oh, I can just like jump there.
You have to know of a good wedding chapel.
Uh, one in Mario Odyssey.
Say, hey Mario, guess what?
Ryan isn't just a friend anymore, we're getting married!
Oh, congratulations on the marriage.
Now I get to jump on your bed before you do marriage duties.
Oh, so fast.
Mario, I make a great psychic for you in a few years, right?
Don't worry if Bowser shows up.
I know just how to get his gult.
I hope my grandchild turns out just to be just like the princess.
It's so nice to see our young ones having a good time.
I want to spa, spa, spa.
Woohoo!
Can I jump around here?
Whee!
Hey, what do you think you're doing? Get off there this minute!
No, bad. I just wanted to jump.
Mario, what a pleasant surprise.
One of the frog stages grandchild is running around errands in town today.
I haven't seen him, though.
Oh, you're here to shop? What are you looking for?
Um, bye.
What's up, pick me up?
I was a down-allied and planning juice.
Refreshing status during battle.
I can carry 10 of them and carry 6 of those.
Oh, I got balls.
Wait, you got shirts and stuff?
It's a shirt. It's a pair of pants.
Jump shoes?
Use jump attacks against any show.
Well, it prevents poison damage.
Shit, should I gotten these?
I'll get more money, right?
I got shirts. I got pants.
I want the jumpshoes.
And an old pin. Okay.
Here you go.
Hey, see ya!
Welcome!
Can jump on your head, because you tricked me.
Star?
I had to crash for a while. Only cost you 3 coins.
No, thanks.
Good luck, Mario.
I'll fuck you. I'm gonna steal this.
I'm gonna steal this. Yeah!
Classic, right?
Yeah.
Come talk to me now.
I'mma jump on him!
Ah, nothing happened.
Not like I'm always sleeping.
Oh wait, you slipped on...
Rip.
Hammer to his face. I don't want to hammer to his face.
Not yet.
What's this?
Background?
Back.
Okay, let's go up some more stairs.
Do-de-de-de-de-de.
Mario, hurry! The Chancellor's awaits!
Mario, hurry! The Chancellor awaits!
Mario, there you are! I'll tell the Chancellor you're here!
I'll wait for you down the hallway!
What do you mean, wait for you down the hallway?
Is this some kind of trick?
I'm guiding the Chancellor. Sorry, but you have to get to Chancellor's permission to pass.
I'm just gonna be a menace.
Vault guard! Better not be goofing off while I'm cleaning the guest room.
Now I'm gonna make a mess of it!
Oh ho! Gimme!
A menace to society!
What's this?
Stairs?
Scrooge.
Okay, since it hasn't returned yet...
Can you imagine how the Chancellor must feel?
Jump of the Princess Bed!
Oh, it's much bouncier!
It makes a more ooh sound.
Look, found peaches.
Hey, what, hey there, what do you think you're doing?
I'll give you this in exchange, just leave everything where it was.
Senpai, what did I find?
What did I find?
Did I find...
Canis?
Hahaha!
Man, he runs too fast.
Sir, Mario has arrived!
This way, please.
Mario, thank goodness you're here!
We heard an explosion or something at Bowser's Keep.
It was so loud I almost dropped my spores.
Excuse me, where's the Princess?
She departed for your house hours ago!
I fear the worst!
Could Bowser somehow be behind all this?
Hey, I turned into Bowser!
Spore's alive, you're telling us that Bowser has abducted the Princess again?
Uh, maybe you...
I don't know, maybe, maybe you guys should do something about that.
Scandalous.
Never mind, it will be up to you to enter the Keep and Rescue Princess Peach.
Uh-uh.
Wow, this sure raises soul, soul, soul dramatic.
Egan, the Keep is unassailable!
What awful powers that work here!
Mario, her life is in your hand, please save our dear Princess.
Hey Mario!
You're making sure to equip the things you get, right?
Shall I have Toad explain the process?
Sure, let's do it.
You'll equip things using the...
Using the menu!
You'll equip things using the menu by pressing the plus button.
Okay.
Please press plus button, got it.
Oh, he's running here!
Mario, choose equip!
Confirm with A!
Please equip these!
Use the hammer and press A!
And you're set!
There, now I feel more at ease.
I'll buy more armor and accessories in the Ninem Shop.
I'll then take care.
Mario!
Forgive me, but I can't stop worrying about the Princess.
Go to the cellar and prepare for your journey.
The vault guard will assist you.
Yeah, treasure!
Mario, the Chancellor has filled me in!
The vault is this way!
Here's the vault, let me show you around.
Hope you stop through the treasures.
This is a mushroom.
But you knew that by looking at it, huh?
These mushrooms get you from...
You get from treasure chests.
Don't work quite like the mushroom items.
Treasure chest mushroom restores both HP and SP when you open the chest.
But you can't save them for later.
Mushrooms you find as items only...
Restore your HP.
But you can take them with you whenever you want.
Oh, okay.
This is a flower.
Flowers or treasure chests work a little differently from those flower items.
Flower chest flower.
Treasure chest flowers.
Oh my gosh, I can't read.
Increase your flower points, HP.
As soon as you grab one, but you can't carry them with you.
Flower tabs on the other hand, you can take with you.
You can use those from the X menu when you increase your HP.
This is a coin.
These ones are worth one, and the large ones are worth ten.
This one's a ten.
That's it? That's all I get?
Dang.
The treasury in this kingdom.
Lacking.
Come back here.
Oh?
Oh, he's sad.
No, no, no. A little...
Popcorn-looking guy.
Ah.
Oh no, that reptile stole my grandpa's coins.
Oh, blue.
I can't cry.
Big boys don't cry, but it's just not fair.
What am I going to do?
Oh, just like me, for real, for real.
There's a secret.
Oh no, he's crying so much.
Was there a secret person somewhere?
No.
Oh, same though. It's okay, bro.
Yeah, gee, you're soaking wet, aren't you?
I'm alright now, sorry.
There's something like a good cry.
I agree.
Oh, why was I crying?
There was some reason.
Oh, you can't remember.
Your grandpa asked me to buy some things for him.
When I walked into town, that croc stopped me.
Oh yeah, he took it from me.
He stole my coin. I chased him, but he's way too fast.
I don't know. Let's see how you're going to take care of Bowser.
Wait, what?
Oh, he doesn't stand a chance.
Wow, you're the Mario.
I know all about you. You've got more jumps in you than a box of frogs.
I'm Malo, the tadpole from the tadpole pond.
I'm a frog.
Oh.
Okay.
But can you believe it? I can't jump.
Embarrassing, huh?
How about it?
Mario, will you help me catch that filthy thief?
Sure thing.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
A young frog, Malo, who doesn't look at all like a frog,
joins Mario in his quest.
Well, at least they're self-aware.
The scrapbook has been added under your journal.
You can check it out to look back on your adventure so far.
Oh.
Hey, you set up for 50 years, dude.
Wow, thank you so much.
You know what, if Malo thinks, yeah, you know, it's fine.
Well, thank you so much.
Hi, I have something to report, sir.
You saw him.
He was here somewhere.
He just zoomed past me a second ago.
Did you see him?
He looks something like this.
Oh, my charades is on point.
Senpais grow.
We'll have to provide more hammers now.
And maybe double tap on some bones.
Oh, yes, exactly.
He's the one who took my coin.
Why didn't you stop them?
Because I forgot my bazooka at home.
Jeez, give me a break here.
Got a bazooka?
Whoa.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Oh, Senpais, you're being so kind today.
Thank you so much, Dastweet.
For the 50, gifted.
Thank you so much.
Wow, my Senpais are so generous and kind today.
I'm getting emotional again.
Just, I'm getting emotional.
Just like, just like Malo, Malo.
We might not have enough hammers.
You're right.
We're going to have a hammer shortage at this rate.
We're going to have to share.
Communal hammers.
Happy tears.
You're going to make me cry happy tears.
Do I have to choose between my hammer and my ping pong paddle now?
I think you're going to be fine, Senpais.
Thank you.
I feel so very blessed right now.
Thank you Senpais.
I'm going to try my best at Mawil.
But I might not be very good at it.
Thank you for, thank you for the $49.99 super griffin for buying more hammers.
Thank you.
Now we have hammers.
Everyone can have hammers now.
Thank you so much.
Everyone's so kind today.
Thank you.
Hammer stock.
I feel so happy.
Thank you.
Can we upgrade to sledge hammers?
Yeah, we'll upgrade to sledge hammers now.
Bigger hammers.
With bigger and stronger weight.
They're going to be so big and so much more forceful.
We are the hammer bros.
Yeah.
Senpais are the hammer bros now.
Come back here.
Har har.
You's mugs will never catch me.
Now could I run you morons later?
Ooh.
That's him.
Hurry Mario.
Let's get him.
Mario, you might want to take this.
Got a map.
If you select map from the menu, you can pick a location to jump to as long as it's somewhere you've been to before.
What a big bottom boom.
I didn't do a great voice, but.
Oh, I wanted to see if there was a guy.
Senpai.
That's a late alert.
Isn't that quite a late alert?
Oh.
Listen, you'd be hiding too if you had a run in with the crocodile creep.
There he found him.
It did have to go through 100 alerts first.
Yeah, that's true.
It finally caught up.
Because Senpais were so kind.
Oh.
There he is.
He's probably stashed it in the big.
Let's nab him.
Are you trying to tell me?
Go home to mommy before you get hurt, kid.
Well, he just far.
And it's way.
Get in here.
F.P. is shared between the entire party.
Should you use an attack or recover?
As you learn specials, think carefully about who's to use.
It's fine.
I'm gonna learn.
I'm gonna practice, Senpai.
What's your attack?
Oh.
Nice.
Okay, we're doing that.
That's a lot of damage.
Yeah.
Get over here.
Big frog guy.
Oh.
Others.
Gage.
Got Gage.
Move.
Hold assist.
Who knows what you might get?
What did I get?
Star gust.
Oh.
Nice.
Hey, get over here.
Get over here.
Oh.
Oh, no.
That was terrible.
Oh.
Oh, that was terrible as well.
There you go.
I'm getting okay.
I'm probably gonna have to use a mushroom though.
A mallow.
Oh, save.
Save.
Ha ha ha.
You couldn't jump to save your life, kid, so I guess this is goodbye.
Wait a second.
I wanna make sure I got everything.
You know?
And explored all my options.
Ha ha ha.
No.
Let me do that again.
Son of a bitch.
No.
How do I get back?
Am I stuck?
I'm so sad.
Lug it.
Hey, nine.
Ooh.
Ah!
Wait, did I not get anything?
Level up.
Mario, reach level three.
Learn to new moves.
Fireball.
Fire away.
Push A repeatedly.
Where should I put it now?
Physical?
More physical?
Or more magic.
Oh, we can do magic.
Ah!
Ah, that's fine.
We're fine.
Platforming, what is that?
Oh, you're a persistent pest, but I'm 100 miles ahead of you.
Wait, what's this way?
Let's see what's this way.
I didn't get coins.
Only XP.
Get everything.
Give it up already, that treasure box is tempting, but now's not the time.
Me.
Ah!
Fuck!
Platforming hard!
Ah!
You sometimes encounter stronger than usual monsters.
Feeding them will get you lots of coins.
Experience an even broad coin.
She's so fine!
Don't worry about it!
Ah!
Do you have a special?
Senpai!
Thank you for the Super Chat, $2 Super Chat, Charlie Spur, Italian, Kohai.
It's a me!
Mercy all!
Come on, try the Thunderbolt.
Oh!
Ah!
Wait, did I use jump or fire?
Shit!
Not bad.
Ah!
Frog coin!
I got one frog coin!
Didn't even need to...
Ah!
Jump on it!
Oops.
Ah!
Level up!
Finally!
This guy needs HP!
You need HP!
I'm going with HP!
You can pass by in the field to use special...
Super Chat.
I WAS going to use specials!
Ah, come on!
What do you mean once again?
Okay.
I can do this!
Oh, fuck!
I can...
Yeah!
Fuck!
Shut up!
I can hear it!
I'm trying!
It's in it!
Fuck you!
And you and you and you!
How do you kids?
Get outta here!
Get outta here, kids!
Get in!
May we'll give up!
He's gone hiding!
Let's see if we can sneak up behind him and catch him.
Oh, I dodged that!
What's this? You fools can't chase down a pumpkin!
Oh, fuck!
Can I get the big frog guy?
Thank you, frog dog.
You can take the Gloombies.
There we go.
Oh, I have to go behind him, right?
Come on, look the other way.
Come on.
Yeah!
What's this? You fools can't chase down a pumpkin!
What the fuck?
Get over here! Get over here!
Okay.
Where's the...
Where is he?
Shut up, shut up, shut up, shut up!
Oh my god, I can't see where he's going.
Your eyes are much faster than your feet.
This rate I have to take.
A hundred more years to catch me.
Punch up on him!
Eh?
I think he just walked into him.
Okay.
He just...
Bug it! Bug it! Bug it! I want to train!
Start training!
These are too distracting.
I need my anger out of nowhere.
Okay.
Ready to go?
Yeah!
You again? This is getting old.
I'll still take you.
Enough! You got me fair and square.
I'll give you back your coin.
Did you really believe me? I was lying!
You bastard! You have, like, barely arms!
Well, here we go.
Ouch!
Okay.
I think I got it.
Ah!
Ten pie!
Oh, give me a moment.
My wrist.
Thank you, Tiny Spinny, for the 3-3-3.
You know, I want to know a fun fact.
If you actually wait 50 years in game,
I'll give up and command you
for waiting 50 years.
Then an instantly more few to the credits,
but only in the original Japanese version.
I didn't even wait that long in game.
Aw, come on!
Come on!
You can get up!
Oops! Forgot the block there.
Not that one.
Stage move.
Quad assist.
Okay.
What's this one?
RSS.
Oh!
Attack up!
Yee!
Yeah!
I did it!
I was so close!
Give me back my coin out!
Felt you again!
Oh, the coin!
Ouch!
I'm going to pay you back in spades, kid.
Go on.
Take back your grubby old coin.
Adios, amigos!
Hey, we got it back!
You win.
Experience 8.
And coin 10.
And a flower tab.
Yee! Mario, reach level 4.
Max HP.
Attack.
Defense.
Magic defense.
You might need more magic.
You think I need to do more magic?
Yeah, you think so.
Or should I do more physical?
Because then I can do more magic, right?
Yeah!
Everyone's like,
Hannah! I want more Hannah power!
I'm going to do magic though,
because I think that's the smarter one.
Yeah, we did it!
We got grandpa's coin back.
I can finish my errand now.
And look at that.
That croc guy left a wallet.
Found a wallet.
He's going to join me.
And use the map to go to the mushroom kingdom together.
Yeah!
Map.
Mushroom.
Yeah.
Mario.
Oh, it's night time.
What's going on flies at night time?
I'm more.
Oh.
Oh, fuck.
I am so bad with Mario.
Oh.
I'm so bad.
Thanks Mario.
I'll continue to stand and watch.
But everyone seems, now everyone seems suspicious.
Hey, look what I found.
Team 10 coins. Oh, thank you.
I'm going to go buy stuff.
Please leave correct amount of money for the items.
Manager.
Oh.
Can only Mario use it?
You don't need any more of this item.
Oh, okay.
I need to pick me up.
Maybe two of them.
Maybe...
Yeah, that's good.
Excuse me!
You want to what? How can you shop at a time like this?
Just take what you want and leave the money behind.
Hold on.
I'm going to...
Got pants?
Weapons? No weapons?
Here, you have to don't pin for you.
Since you are...
Since you are like a... I don't fucking know.
You are like a house of glass.
8 p-rains. Okay.
8 p-rains.
Oh, level up. Finally.
I... I think you need more physical, but I feel like your magic is way better.
Your magic is way better, but your physical sucks.
That was two turn close.
Thanks for the hand, Mario.
Hey, there's the wall at the crocodile's side for me.
Can I have it back? Sure.
Thank you so much.
Here, I'll give you this as a reward.
Go on, take it.
Thank you.
I'm going to use flower tab.
Can I just use it?
Is it... is it like a recovery one?
Is it... is flower tab like permanent?
Permanent?
Permanent.
It's permanent, right?
Okay.
Oi.
Yeah.
Right, you used the jar. It's three tabs. Okay, I will.
Shut them up, I criticize.
Yeah.
Okay.
Oops.
Yeah.
No more.
I'm killing all of them.
Okay.
The frog powers.
How many more of them are there?
Okay.
Oh, I missed.
I missed.
Yay, I won.
There's infinite coming out of the door.
Okay.
You okay?
Mario, look what you're standing in.
Ah, gotcha.
So...
What do I do?
Okay, uh...
Oh, shut up.
The princess kidnapped by those things outside?
Are they a part of this?
Oh, maybe I should save, yeah.
Classic save.
Yay.
Back to mushroom kingdom.
Oh, they are coming out of the castle.
I guess I'll have to just...
force my way in.
Oops.
Oh, come on.
Okay.
I'm about...
to tetral hands.
Literally.
How's your rash?
It's down quite a bit, Senpai.
It heats up every once in a while,
but it's not itchy anymore, so it's still good.
What do you think everyone won?
All gang looks like we have...
we have ourselves a new home.
We pass around all day long,
and there's no one here who can stand in our way.
That's what we're leaving here.
What did the doctor say about it, though?
He said it was an allergic reaction,
and that was it.
Well, hi. Can we start a pogo stick gang?
I have terrible balance,
so I wouldn't even be able to go on a pogo stick.
Wow, helpful, huh?
Yeah, I mean,
I probably will have to cancel
my dermatologist...
uh...
thing.
But I, like,
basically washed...
everything.
That's the night away.
Not so fast, pal.
I can't even bounce.
Maybe we can bounce on this head.
Oh my gosh!
You're using the sword as a pogo stick!
Listen up, gang.
These guys are gonna put a stop to our party.
Are you happy about this?
You're asking for it?
Oh, you're gonna get it.
Pick the wrong people
not to bounce with, bub.
How about a fat lip
to go with that ugly mustache?
All right.
Should I get rid of the bodyguards first?
I'm gonna jump on his head.
Then...
Thunderbolt?
Ah!
No, yo!
Thanks!
Oh!
Ah!
Okay.
Relief!
Nah, not yet.
I can do Thunderbolt.
I can't block it!
Okay, understood.
Now I'm just gonna hit you with my hammer.
Okay.
Ah!
Oh, come on.
My timing is so bad right now.
Ah!
I only have this honey syrup.
It's fine.
Why am I so bad at video games?
Right, I can't block that.
Okay.
Focus!
Sorry for silence. I'm focusing.
Okay.
Yay!
One again, one again.
Why is there a blue star there?
As blue as Mario's eyes!
I thought Mario's eyes were green though, to be honest.
It's not good.
A mustachioed is strong.
Strong, yes.
A must born the boss.
Come on.
Gracious!
Oh, it's you, Mario. What a relief.
Once again, Mario, to the rescue.
Oh, sorry. I need the voice.
Who are those?
Chancellor!
Sir, thank goodness you're all right.
Shut the fuck up, Siri.
Shut the fuck up, Siri, that was...
Did you?
Sometimes you hear that?
No? Okay.
Okay.
So, I was like, Chancellor,
and then Siri suddenly went up and went,
you're welcome, and I went...
Mario, so you got through all this.
We all smug to you.
No.
I got so scared, but I was like,
whoa!
Glad it wasn't worse.
Yeah, me too. I'm going to have to figure out how to turn that off.
I didn't realize.
I've never used it before, so...
It never came up until now?
No.
First the princess, now this. It's just too much to bear.
Mario, how about you ask my grandpa
for help? He knows everything.
Excuse me, but who are you?
Oh, hello. My name is Mao.
I'm from Tadpole Pond.
Any friends of Mario's welcome here
in the Mushroom Kingdom.
As I was saying, Mario,
you're our only hope.
Mario, please, you must rescue
the princess now!
I know, I'm in your debt, too.
Let's head over to grandpa's place
in Tadpole Pond. You can help.
Wait, why did I even come to the Mushroom Kingdom
in the first place?
Please don't find us in enough!
You were supposed to...
to get something.
Heh, heh, to get something.
Could Clay Martin,
the sword-like monster who crashed
into the Mushroom Kingdom,
have anything to do with the star piece
that Mario found?
Our heroes moved on towards
the Kero Sewers. Kero Kero.
Kero-chan!
Kero mentioned.
Look, I better not be goofing off.
The actual beginning.
Yeah.
I'm so bad at video games.
Oh!
Oh, now it's
everything's normal again.
Careful, the monster! Smash him all!
Do ya good, trust me on this one.
I guess the Princess Peach World really was
kidnapped by Bowser.
Hey, Mario, look where you're standing.
Ha, gotcha!
That was too darn close.
Thanks for the hand, Mario.
I'll make a great
sidekick.
Oh, my grandchild turns out
to be just like the Princess.
I'll remain here for the lookout.
Do I need to pick up anything?
I probably need to pick up things, huh?
Hey, Mario,
what kept you out of starting to worry?
Hey, mister, I got my coin back.
Oh, well done, lad.
Okay, here's the thing I promised you.
There, make sure it doesn't get stolen
or whatever, your grandpa needs it, okay?
Got cricket pie.
You bet.
I don't think so much.
Grandpa will be delighted.
I get actual items, thanks.
Okay, I want
some mushrooms.
Some honey pseudo.
Okay, that's good.
Save, I need to save.
I know that it's...
Oops, I know that it auto-saves,
but, you know...
Okay, where do I need to go?
Here?
I think...
This is the entrance.
Grandpa says to watch out for bellum.
Well, whatever, whoever that is,
probably a little dark down there, so keep alert.
Haha.
Oh, I have to save here again.
Kiddosuers.
Ooh, I swim.
Ooh, how...
Gross.
Reading directions on how to enter?
Yes.
Stand on pipe, push A.
Do we enter a pipe?
Jump off once and try again.
Okay.
Is there anything around here?
Ah! Freaking rats!
I didn't know Emmy was here.
That Emmy was on vacation.
Fucking rats.
Die!
Freaking rats.
A lucky...
...
I am pure water.
I got flour.
Hey!
Ho-what?
It's a ho-what?
Oh.
Oh, your heart's broken. It's okay.
Don't worry. Don't be scared.
Just a little guy.
The feet's undead in a wink.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Mario gets a fuck back up.
Mario!
Ah!
Arh!
Mario!
I'm gonna do physical this time.
You won't turn into mushrooms or Scarecrolls.
Oh, how do I go down?
Oh, shit.
Yeah.
Wait, I unequipped Mario's armor?
Did I?
Oopsie-daisy!
That was my bad.
Can I beat a Shadow?
Yeah, why not?
Our mushroom!
Thanks!
Oh, attack up, thank you!
Whoa.
Oh, you can literally just hammer it, okay?
Your HP sucks, but also give me more magic.
Oh, why did it run away?
Hmm.
There's something over there.
Oh.
Oh, shit, I'm poisoned.
My timing's so bad.
What's with this guy and so much HP?
There we go.
Oh, I got a frog coin, that's why.
Right, oh.
Like this? Yeah.
That's right, run!
Oh, you spooked me!
There we go.
There's a button there.
Water has been drained.
Sorry, it's funny to see these fish on land.
There it is.
Yeah, I can save here again, yeah.
How do I get up there, though?
Big door, I think there's a switch somewhere.
Giddle, giddle.
That must be film.
Not a fire hose, or his tongue.
Oh, it's snack attacking, you're it!
It's kind of cute, right?
Can I do a fireball on it?
I suck.
Well, room service has been kind to me.
Where's my bib?
Okay, let's try this again.
I fell asleep.
Stick for a body, and full of straw.
Give me a scarecrow, rah, rah, rah.
I can't, it's hunger, the hunger.
I got it!
Spin it out!
Bad dog, bang.
Good. That was scary!
Dump.
Ah!
I guess I'll defend, right?
Oh, keep defending!
Can you still do this?
You think you won, huh?
Little did you know.
I'm out of stopping of flood water.
So long, Sokies!
Thanks for the money, but also...
What?
That one must have been lying when he said he'd water would come gushing out of here.
Er, Mario, did you hear something, or is it just me?
Water, here it comes! We need to switch it back before we're washed away!
There's a button right there, can I just... yeah.
Oh! Oh!
I'm in Splash Mountain now!
This is the minus river course.
What did I have to say?
Water crash course isn't yes.
To start off, first at the falls, use L to move left or right and squirt coins.
Press V to make a little headway against the flow.
Okay, on the way there are a few holes, as well as what will happen.
Just keep that a surprise.
Off you go!
I can get coins?
Frog coin!
I want my frog coin! Give me my frog coin!
Frog! Frog! Frog! Frog!
Yeah.
Frog, frog, frog, frog, frog coin!
That's most important, right? It's the frog.
Ah! Where's the holes?
It really is like Splash Mountain, except for...
I don't know.
Oh, by the way...
Sorry, I meant...
Visually distinct Splash Mountain.
Okay, here we go.
Give me my frog coin!
Give me the con!
Rock, coin, coin.
Rock, coin.
Rock, rock, rock, rock, rock, rock, rock.
Rock, rock, rock, rock.
Rock, rock, rock.
Rock.
Cling.
Whee.
What's this?
jetzt we're the bear jumping it.
No.
Awww.
Need some pointers?
Yeah.
I'm gonna jump and grab coins along the way.
Some pies already know how bad I am at platforming.
I'm going to the next barrel before they collide.
Is it a new change course?
Looks like you're ready so I'll send you on your way.
No, I'm ready.
Almost forgot to tell you, leap over the fish that pop up or you'll lose coin.
Shut up.
What?
Oh my god!
Wait!
Shut up, bitch!
Pay the coins you got from Midas River for frog coins.
That's not enough to cash in so hold on.
So I'll hold on for them for you, okay?
Come back and try again.
Just look up.
Here's something I picked up.
You can keep it for good luck.
Fuck Koopa Shell.
Shut the fuck up!
Okay, let's equip Koopa Shell.
shirt
pants
So weapon call high.
Koopa Shell kicked to attack.
Does Malo not have any?
Should I try it?
I'll give it a shot.
What's going on here?
Melody Bay.
How do you know it's by jumping on the tadpoles?
Tadpoles.
Let's hear your melody.
I won't play with strangers.
They won't play with strangers so go and meet this frog sage first.
Okay.
Okay, frog sage first.
Other way.
Hi, can I help you?
Oh, it's you!
You've heard about your adventures with Super Mario.
Meet up Bellum, right?
You know about that?
Hey Mario, the waterways of the world brings news to us here.
That's why Grandpa knows all the news that's fit to hear.
Are you really the Super Mario?
Hey everyone, you never guess who's here.
He's the real thing.
But he doesn't look anything like I thought he would.
You say you can jump better than a froggy.
I wonder if there's only a rumor?
I'm so excited!
Wow, wow, what's new?
You're so excited!
Grandpa, Mario's been helping me.
I know a child that's brainstormed.
We just had algae, wasn't it?
Ouch.
Watch it up there.
It's supposed to make me look like I'm floating here, okay?
Oh, how, how, how very, how are you sage of you?
With your, with your frog sage wisdom.
Welcome, so you are Mario.
Yes, I am frog sage.
You have come to seek wisdom from me.
Have you not?
I've been waiting for you.
Yes, old wise people can often give good advice.
Hey, senpai, since you're so old and wise,
can you bestow upon your kohai some sage old wisdom?
Old people knowledge?
Every 60 seconds a minute passes.
Thank you.
Frogfuges, let's go.
Always look both ways before you cross the road.
But how rude of me.
Let me get more comfortable.
Come along and we'll talk.
Clear, far, well, full reverse.
Ted Poles, don't just float there.
Make yourself useful.
Form a bridge for Mario.
I get to use them on the bridge?
Yes, come into my sanctuary and partake of my wisdom children.
If a raw egg floats in water, it's rotten.
I don't even need to know that because I avoid eggs at all costs.
You kind of need to yourself whether it's buying extra ice cream
or another Pokemon thing.
Comparison is a theft of joy and if you're going to compare,
compare your past progress.
Now how versus now it's to your girlfriend.
Wow, that one's really wise.
So wise and sage-like.
Evil eggs.
All eggs are evil and should be eradicated.
Let's see.
That's Smithy character that appeared at Bowser's Keep.
He's quite formidable, yes.
Mario, do we wish to rescue the princess?
Quickly do not.
I mean, he always wants to rescue the princess.
Even your eggs call hi.
I'm allergic to...
What's the word?
Bird eggs.
The bird eggs.
You think I'm a bird?
Oh, you only knew the truth.
Peach is no longer there.
This is dramatic.
Patience, young one, let me explain.
Here's what happened.
You were rescuing Peach from Bowser's Keep
after defeating him just when you were about to free the princess.
There was a loud crash and saw a huge sword split the sky.
Ooh, exactly like that, yes.
Everyone's so good at charades here.
Bush out of the blue.
The shots and the three of you flying.
Bowser and Peach are lost somewhere out there now.
You're worried about the princess,
but first you need to take care of Smithy.
His underlings are wreaking havoc in our world.
Clay Morton, whom you defeated at the Mushroom Kingdom,
was one of them.
More will be coming.
Grandpa, I almost forgot to tell you something.
I'm a star in the Mushroom Kingdom castle.
Do you know why I was there?
Star, eh?
Most interesting.
This may sound illogical,
but I believe shooting stars can grant wishes.
And now, more than ever,
I believe they will play a vital role in the fight against Smithy.
Not too much to absorb, would you like to recap?
Oh no, we're good, we're good.
It's quite a situation we have in our hands, isn't it?
Wow, everything sounds so dire and serious.
I guess Clay Morton was real.
Only the first of many, Mario.
Some of them make Bowser seem nice.
Mario, you speak as if these things cannot concern you.
You accompany Mario on his adventure too.
Grandpa, what are you talking about?
I'm only a simple tadpole, this adventure isn't for me.
Mario, my boy.
Mallowa, my boy.
I've kept this from you until now,
but you're not a tadpole.
Say what?
Whoa!
What do you mean?
I can't believe it, no way!
I was sitting here one rainy day,
enjoying a snack of crickets.
We can't believe it, Senpai!
Who could have seen this coming?
When I happened to see basket floating down from the falls,
I peeked inside and saw a little baby staring right back at me.
Name, Mallow, was written on his belt.
I felt sorry for the little bundle of puff,
and took him in to raise it as my own grandchild.
And powerful magic, and I knew he was more than a piece of fluff.
I thought surely this child must be from some far off land.
Grandpa, you mean it?
I'm not a tadpole!
Mallowa!
Now is not the time to cry.
Go with Mario on his adventure,
and find your real family.
Your real mother and father are out there, so where?
Mario.
Boy's magic is sure to come in handy on your adventure.
Take him along, right?
Oh!
Grandpa, I won't cry anymore.
I'll go on this adventure with Mario, and find my real family.
And it's settled.
You must embark on your adventure immediately.
First, go to Rose Town, and I need your help.
Are you okay?
I'll be quieter.
It will be quiet around here with my Mallowa gone.
Give me a snack, would hear me out.
That's right, I forgot about it!
I gave me some of the Cricket Pie you brought back.
I will give you something for the Cricket Pie you brought back.
I know.
You shall have the staff I used when I was Mallow's age.
The Froggy Stick will come in handy.
Do not forget to equip it.
Okay, he's okay again!
I'll keep sticking.
Go to Rose Town, luck be with you.
Sounds, laughter, mirth, reverie, donuts, reading, dolphin, relax.
A few notes on my latest tune.
Hold on.
Do I need to write this down?
Senpai, do I need to write this down?
Sounds, laughter, mirth, reverie, donuts, reading.
Pinch show.
No, not Pippa.
Not Pippa.
There we go.
Your table, it's mine.
Okay.
And I get the fuck out of here.
Okay, there we go.
Thanks tadpoles.
It's a me, Merciel.
Got in this dream of becoming a composer.
Maybe as famous as Tawatsuki.
My favorite song?
Frog Sage, sweet number...
Number 18.
Solami de do, do de do de.
Tawatsuki's fond of it too.
Oh!
You see.
That's something you can pose.
No, that's not the right melody.
That's not the right melody.
Give me a second.
How does this work?
You, speak to me.
Favorite song?
Solami de do, do de do de.
Tawatsuki de do, do de do de.
Do I have to mention those?
I don't know which way it goes.
Sol?
Wait, what?
Solami de do, do de do de.
Oh.
Wait, did I fuck up?
Oh fuck.
My bad.
No, it's missing fa.
Okay.
I can't, I don't know music very well.
Okay, hold on.
Do de do, do de do.
No, do?
Sol?
I can talk to him again.
Just decide to go like this.
Yeah, straight line.
And the composer, Tawatsuki.
And you create my next next piece, but I got composer's block.
Want a music lesson from me?
Yes!
Let's start by reading notes.
See the five lines?
Between the second and third lines from the top lies do.
Do.
Like this one?
Keep going from do, re, mi.
Ti, la, so, fa.
Oh my gosh.
Hold on.
Going up.
Do de mi.
Ti, la, so, fa.
Okay.
Do de mi, ti, la, so, fa.
This doesn't seem right.
You're on your way to composing.
Okay.
Oh shit, I think I did it wrong.
That's remarkably similar to what I have in mind.
I'm so close!
I was really close!
Okay, okay.
Hold on.
Do de mi.
Okay.
This one.
Why?
Ti.
Mother was also trying to believe her father was realistic capacity.
Clearly, it's almost impossible to say that I and her mother were speaking their native language.
That's not going to work without us.
May I again? Yeah. Day.
That's it! This is the melody I've been looking for. Thank you for the inspiration.
Please take this as a token of my gratitude.
Got the Alto card.
You ever need help with my composition again? I'll look for you here.
Until then, edgy.
Yay! Let's go!
You look fun.
See what that toad says.
Can't wait to graduate from music school and start composing.
Thank you, wise toad.
Head up north from the exit to find where you used the card. Here?
Okay.
Go back and turn right.
Wait, shouldn't we look into how to use the fraud coins?
Oh yeah, maybe we should do that.
What?
Welcome to Fraud Coin and Brorium. Hey, the first timer, aren't you? Listen up.
The green coins you find periodically are fraud coins.
You can lay them and buy items at tadpole pond.
Sleepy bomb.
Bracer.
Energizer.
Cardi-bracer.
Cardi-energizer.
Sleepy bomb.
Might be handy.
Welcome to Juice Bar.
You're a card member?
Even Tomatsuki has a membership here.
Ah, an Alto card.
Alto card.
What would you like?
Goodbye.
Tadpole.
Tadpole cola.
Ooh.
Frogleg cola.
Oh, God.
Free of those.
Free of those. Yeah.
What leg cola? Frogleg cola.
What's this? Look.
Yellow.
Tiles on Mc Lake Harry.
And you hop on them.
You can't jump off a tile when it's blue.
Oh.
I accidentally won't walk out.
Thank you.
Bye.
Star slap.
Oh.
Slap the star.
No, I don't want to be slapped.
Oh.
I like the hammer better, guys.
Lullaby.
Doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo.
Oh, fuck.
My.
Fuck.
I got so bright.
My.
Yeah.
Fuck.
Oh, look, hey, listen here, that's a big ass splitter!
Was that supposed to be the same?
Friday with fire!
Well, he's got the numpad in his pocket...
Bro!
Wait, what are you doing here??
Oooh!
Girl, disgusting!
Yo!
You grills, grills, grills, disgusting, you grills.
Oh my gosh, how much?
Oh, there we go.
Oh, give me a second.
Oh, am I not strong enough?
Ugh. Jesus.
I'm gonna learn! I'm going to learn how to do this, Senpai.
The hardest boss in the game. I'm terrible at platformers.
I just only need to jump on the other one like this one.
Aw.
Ehh.
Blah.
I think I should go right here.
No.
Shhh. Close. Close your eyes, Senpai.
Close your eyes, Senpai.
Yes!
Okay, now I'm back to being bad at video games.
Thank you. No! Can't get me back here!
Fuck.
Ehh.
Okay.
Ah.
I'm your twerp.
Blah!
Okay. I got it.
Now does seem stronger, yeah.
Alright. Right, sorry.
No, I missed!
Aw, come on.
There you go.
Whee! I still need to do timing for, oh fuck.
Meow.
Hm?
Ehh.
Meow.
Aw, missed.
Are they gonna be both asleep now?
No!
I'll have one more pick me up.
Alive!
Oh, Mario! Stop being the honkshoos!
Stop me-me-me-me!
Oh my god.
They're co-easy!
One more, one more.
Guess I can train here.
There you go.
Okay, those were easy to block, I could hear it.
I could hear the melody.
Yeah.
Wait, they didn't give me anything.
Okay.
Ehh.
I'm winning!
Level six, super jump!
I want more physical.
Yeah.
There's just so much.
Well, time to level up.
Yeah.
Oh shit.
Yeah, I'm getting it.
I'm getting it.
Do-do-do-do-do-do.
Come here.
My timing's off now.
I need a mushroom for this biatch.
Yeah!
Level up!
More magic.
Yes!
Yeah.
Going on here.
Those are so cute though.
Alright people, form ranks!
Jaeger, head of the shooting warrior.
This is a Koopa master of the hooded sorcerers.
And last but not least, Goom Hilda.
Grand Dame of the grounding Goombas.
This is our finest moment.
Bowser's minions are invincible.
We shall be victorious.
The bridge is down, but we'll find a way to get back in.
Move out on the double!
Bowser and his minions must be on their way to Bowser's keep.
Come on, Rosetown is just up ahead.
Is this Rosetown?
Wait, is he going to attack Rosetown?
No!
Wait, you okay?
The arrow's coming out from the forest and when you're hit you can't move.
See, look, can't move a muscle.
Now I know how a scarecrow feels.
This is the day a shooting star fell into the forest.
The arrows have been showering our town.
Now you can't move.
Mario, help!
Hey Mario, I'll be taking care of the princess now.
Boing boing! Super jump attack!
They're kissing.
Oh, they kissed.
You think you can hurt me with your childish pranks?
Attention, Peach.
Attention, Peach, you're coming with me.
Zip your lip.
Help, help, somebody help, please help me.
Oh my gosh.
It's mom, mom.
Mom, mom, we have a guest.
Yes, dear, I hear you.
Why, hello, why aren't you Mario?
Priya?
Oh, you have the hat and the funky stash.
Are you really Mario?
You betcha on a wrong number.
Are you betcha?
Wrong number.
Okay, where are you betcha?
I'm gonna say you betcha.
But I know it's you.
You might be pulling my leg.
Show me, prove it.
Alright, hey Mario, wanna play with me?
I'm playing Save the World.
Now, guys, Mario might be a little tired, dear.
Oh, come on, mom, you never play with me.
It's no fun playing alone.
Oh dear Mario, I hate to ask,
but could you play with guys for a little while?
Yes, Mario, just bought the farm,
so I'll be Bowser.
I'll be Gino, okay?
Ready, let's play for Mario let's go.
Oh, scary, but just watch me.
Oh, hey, this is the character
that all the Smash people keep on talking about.
The emo Pinocchio.
I remember every time they had like a Smash, like,
like, event.
Every single person who's a fan of this would go berserk.
They would go berserk.
Better watch out Bowser, cause Gino.
Gino?
Gino.
Now it's like, guy, oh, shut up.
Don't you know.
Gino.
You're a turn, Bowser.
Ow!
Oh no, if he keeps this up, I'm finished.
Alright, you ask for it.
Super, duper!
Custom pat new one and only shooting star shot!
Oh!
Oops, I, uh, I think I missed.
Oh dear, oh my.
Mario, are you alright?
Oh.
Damn.
Here he is!
The emo!
The emo Pinocchio!
Get in the Pinocchio!
He's a real boy now.
Look, I'm a real boy.
Give me crickets.
I'm your, I'm your conscious.
Look at me.
Pop!
Wee.
Oh, yeah, let's save this.
I drank, I drank some tea.
But I'm still sleepy.
Mom!
You'll never believe what I just saw.
It's amazing, Mom.
I just saw Kino walk into the forest, neat, huh?
Yes, dear, that's nice, dear.
Didn't you know the one who broke my lap the other day?
Aw, Mom, that was just, well, you know, now this was real.
I swear, Mom, it's really true.
I saw him outside.
All right, guys, let's hear it.
What are you trying to get out of this time?
Um, I didn't do anything.
I really, truly saw Kino walk into the forest.
Sorry I knocked you down a while ago.
Kino doesn't know his own spin.
Oh, boy, this is incredible.
Oh, boy, this is impossible.
Okay, well, I guess we go out and check things out.
Oh, this is not good.
Now I can't go into the forest to chop any wood.
I'm just going to go into people's houses now.
My husband still hasn't come back.
I swear, what's keeping him?
I tell you, it's scary out here.
Someone's got to pump the water.
I'm about to pump in some water for us.
I wish we could help too.
It turns out to go outside is dangerous.
I'm worried about my grandson.
He went out to play but didn't come back when he should have.
I'm going to go someplace fun.
Standing around here is so boring.
There's things and stuff.
Hello, Maria.
It's so nice of you to drop by the shop.
What can I do for you?
Big shirt.
Big pants.
Yes.
Jump shoes.
Ended up in wake up pin.
True farm pin.
Fearless pin.
I don't know.
Mario, good to have a customer at last.
What do you need?
Mushroom.
Onion.
This.
There you go.
Can I go in here already?
Yes, I already went in here.
It's a stay way that leads to my house,
but my son's been playing with the controls again.
Mario, only you could jump up there.
Please.
Let me get back to my house.
Okay.
How do I get back up?
Do I like jump on things and go weak?
Oh.
Is this the forest?
Now there is the forest.
Can we push these boxes?
No.
Arn.
Well.
Horse maze.
Mushroom.
I can pick up mushrooms.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Mushroom.
Not mushroom.
Yes.
I got it.
Disgusting.
Mushroom.
Not real mushroom.
I want in a mushroom.
Mushroom.
I just wanted some mushrooms.
Get over here.
That's right.
Run away, rats.
Run away.
Anything else over here?
Okay, fine.
I'll fight you.
Oh, it's got a stinger.
What's this egg?
Egg shell.
Thanks.
Defense up.
Okay.
Man.
Oh, wait, resistance.
I should heal up.
Wow.
And.
What's, well, well, well, what's all this now?
Oh, did I just dodge it?
Hmm?
No mushroom.
Yep.
Yeah, fuck.
Oh, dang.
I turned into mushroom.
Yeah.
I turned into mushroom again.
Oh, shit.
No, not the double mushroom.
Okay.
I feel like I could definitely get rid of those.
Yeah.
Done.
Left yield's nothing.
Right, yields.
Anything?
Yeah.
Okay.
Okay, there's anything here, so.
Come on here.
Cool.
Ah!
Come on, bitch!
Hello!
Okay.
In the nose here.
Okay, kill this guy, too.
Okay.
Are they?
Ah!
Time's a special nu-
Oh, fuck.
No!
No, no, no, no, no!
Son of a bitch.
Okay.
Man!
Our first death!
I got stopped!
Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah, raise your level.
I know, I know.
Useless, useless.
Maybe not as useless.
No, I've been here already.
Okay.
Wake up, Madel.
Yeah, frickin'...
You're a frickin' glasshouse.
Okay.
Ah!
Yeah.
Oh, yeah!
Yeah, mushroom.
Okay.
It's rocked right into that.
I get no coins, but I get experience.
Damn.
Okay.
Mushroom?
Real mushroom.
Hey, Gino!
Push mushroom into the storage box.
Can't carry any more of an item.
Any extras are sent to the storage box in Mario's pad.
You can take items out of storage there.
Nice!
Which means I can just, like, grab all these...
Mushrooms?
Neat.
Three mushrooms!
Wait, where did that bastard...
Where'd he go?
Oh.
Thank you.
Not the mushroomify!
Oh, come on.
Stop bullying me!
Which way did he go?
There he is.
Fuck.
Gino!
Stop running!
Here, I know this one first.
Okay.
Thanks!
That was a mushroom.
Okay.
Put mushroom in storage box.
Gino, come back to me!
No!
Please.
Ah!
Where are you?
Where are you going?
The safe.
Am I in Twubble?
Bow year?
997?
998?
999?
1000?
Nya ha ha!
1000 arrows!
For cover they run!
Nya!
Fun misses!
Yes!
Nya!
Fun misses!
Yes!
Nya!
Another 1000 will I shoot?
Who's that guy?
He must be the one shooting arrows at Roastown.
Bow year.
Right.
He's kind of ugly.
After I am Nya, look at the expressions when I freeze.
When freeze they do.
They're standing like statues.
Nya!
Marpexes do I need.
Oh no, he's not stopping.
We gotta do something.
What do you think you are?
You can't just go in there with your fists flying.
Too many of them.
We'll be creamed.
Oh no, someone's coming.
Let's hide and see if they can learn anything.
A star!
Nya!
Look what I found, Boyer.
What?
The star of me you must not practice thing I am.
More arrows I must shoot, more statues I must make.
Nya!
Stop.
Hold it right there.
You don't know what you're doing.
Return that star to me.
Nya!
Stranger you are.
Stranger looking at that.
Who's in charge?
Who might you be, Nya?
I serve a higher authority.
That star piece belongs to everyone.
You can't keep it.
Nya!
Alas, the knight will teach you.
Hey, chill out.
Mario's dangerous out there.
We're gonna help, huh?
Blackout, weirdo.
Save guy in blue.
Me too.
I will do what I can.
But from over here.
I'm not afraid.
And I'm not gonna cry.
Nya!
Stop it, that's enough.
Strong you are.
But stronger I am.
I hurt you, I will.
So long.
Nya!
Part now we must.
Thanks for your help.
Who are you?
Mario, you just ditched me back there.
I know you, you look familiar.
So, you're the Mario.
We know about you.
Nya!
Insulted I am!
Alright.
Hey, chill.
Alright, defense up.
Fine.
Now, how do we do this?
I'll just do an attack.
Special.
On the boat, please.
Alright.
I'll just do an attack.
Special.
On the boat, please.
Alright.
Nya!
Now three against one.
Fair.
Fix it I will.
Nya!
Chewing narrow I shall.
And I...
When I target and hit stuff, I'm locked.
And locked are tortoises.
Nya!
Fair fight just between us.
No more tortoises.
Obey my own rules I will.
So no complaints.
Nya!
Wait, what?
You know, beam.
Hold A for power.
And release that max.
Like this.
Oh, okay.
A's off!
Oh shit, I did it too soon.
That was not bad.
Come on, wake up, Gino.
Press A for sequence.
What the fuck is this?
Well, okay.
Lies off, okay.
That's fine.
Okay.
Ow.
Wake up Mario.
Metc Tobler
and
I
You ready?
Wake up, Kino!
Oh, do I hold it? Oh, sorry. I confused myself. Sorry.
I understood the assignment now! I understood the assignment now!
Can I use the mushroom on myself?
Can I use the mushroom on Malo?
Oh, sorry. I understood the assignment now!
Off, off, off.
What are you going to do? You won't let us use a single move.
Listen, everyone. Proving that we're quite the team.
Join forces. All three of us at once. Take them down.
Say what? Yeah, for a dirty trick, you use the same stand-up hole. Yeah.
Oh, oh, oh, yeah. No allies do I have to join forces with.
You can now use triple moves. These powerful moves are available once the gauge is at 100.
Just this once will fill your gauge for free.
Triple.
Alright.
Oh!
How cute!
Power of friendship! You win!
Kind of flower box.
Thanks for your help. You really got me out of a jam.
Are you staring at me? You know I'm more than just a doll, don't you?
Uh-huh, uh-huh. Oh yeah, oh yeah.
Have you guessed the truth? I'm a visitor from above. This is a form I'm borrowing briefly.
Whoa! You mean, like, from the sky or something?
Higher than that, I'm afraid. Do you two know anything about the Star Road?
No.
No? Completely in the dark, eh?
Oh, it's a big mess up there right now, and it concerns you too. Let me explain.
You've heard of wishing upon a shooting star?
At the Star Road, your wish is transformed into a star.
When it's granted, then it then turns into a shooting star and falls down to earth.
So you see, the Star Road plays an integral role in granting wishes.
But, ever since a sword destroyed the Star Road, everything's come to a halt.
No star has been made since. The way things stand, yours is a world where wishes can't come true anymore.
Are you saying this star is part of your Star Way?
That's Star Road, my fluffy little friend. Yes, this star is a broken piece of the Star Road.
I'm here to find them all and repair the Star Road.
For broken star pieces, there are seven all together.
For peace to return, let's get rid of Smithy.
Find the star pieces and repair the Star Road.
I'm...what?
I don't know. I just decided to pick a sound.
That's hard to pronounce, so...
Call me Gino after the doll.
I chose him because he looked the strongest out of the dolls.
Now grab the star, Mario.
Did he just call Mario looking weak?
Come on, let's get the show on the road.
Gino, who is searching for the pieces of the Star Road, joins Mario and Mallow.
Things are definitely looking up.
Oh, I heard everything who would have known that star was so important.
Gotta inform Smithy.
The secret to the shooting stars has been unraveled.
Find the star pieces and bring peace back to Mario's world.
Come here, towel tail!
Ooh! Everything's back to normal now.
Things are finally back to normal. Thank you, Mario.
I can finally move. Guess I owe a doll to Mario. What an amazing guy.
Gino, you came back!
Mommy!
Mom, this is the Gino I was talking about.
My, my. What a fabulous costume. It'd be kind of hard for the person wearing it, though.
I'll forget it, Mom. Alright, Gino, let's play.
How I wish I could. Mario and I must leave to find the missing star pieces.
Star pieces? You mean shooting stars? What for?
Well, how can I explain this?
Oh, guys, it's like this.
It's how it used to be, but now it's like this.
This. Do you get it?
Uh-huh. Uh, uh, nope, you lost me.
Let's just say that if things stay the way they are, your wishes will never come true.
What? So you mean, even if I grow up, I won't be strong and cool like you?
No one's wishes will come true until the star pieces are found.
A star road repaired.
That's why I've chosen to join these two in order to find the missing star pieces.
Oh, that's it. Oh, Mario. Oh, Mario needs all the help he can get.
Is he about to punch this kid?
Is he about to kill this child?
You know what? I did see something sparkly fall somewhere near Movil.
You think? It's one of those things you're looking for, Tino?
Seems highly probable. We'll make Movil our next stop. Thank you for telling us about it.
I'll be waiting for you.
You still fix the star road and make sure all my dreams come true.
That's a promise.
Oh, wait a minute. Wait a minute.
This is yours, Tino. Let's take it along with you.
Got a finger shot.
Thanks for being good support, Gazz. See you when I attack.
Look at him, Tino. You're the main man.
You're the main man.
Mario, how are you feeling?
You need coffee. Keep away.
Yes, you look awesome. Why don't you rest some more?
Right here.
Inequip the item.
Here.
We should buy Tino stuff. Yeah, we should.
Aw, now the kids are doing it.
That was close, but I made it on time.
I'm so proud of my grants. I'm so proud of my grants. Let's just look at them.
Now I can finally go to the forest to chop wood.
I think they're finally back to normal. Thank you, Mario.
Thought I heard a big boom from over the mountains. Starting to hear things.
Hello, Mario. It's nice of you to drop by the shop. What can I do for you?
No. No.
No. Are these too expensive?
I can put on the jumpshoes, and you can have the true warm fin. Yeah.
Yeah, plenty of money, though. Not too much money.
There you go. I got it.
I got it.
Hmm.
And look, the secret!
Send me another house to have, like, I can go onto other houses?
No, I can't.
I don't like it up here. I want to go up here.
Let me up. Let me up.
I don't want to go to your house. I want to go to your house, mister.
I want to go to your house, mister.
Alright, someone asked earlier about what is your favorite essay about Hargapter Sakura?
Um, the ones that have a lot of heart in it.
Jump on the Toad's head. Can I do that? I guess I can, right?
Wait, no.
Can I?
Stay still.
Oh, my God.
Oh, my God. Oh, yeah! We got it!
Huh.
What's Daddy taking so long? Do you think he's still looking for the treasure?
Oh, hey.
Thanks, Million Mario. Say, for my treasures. Okay.
Ow!
I-I will...
Um, about that. I mean, I've taken them.
Um...
I wouldn't say so.
You're kidding.
What? They're gone, Mario! You're the only one who can reach them!
Sorry, I got carried away.
Well, since we didn't get hit by any arrows, I'll tell you a secret.
Enter the forest when you hit an area with a corp...
Corpap.
Wait, hold on.
Left.
Right.
You'll surely find something nice.
I'm sorry, I got carried away!
I'm sorry, that was my fault!
Uh-huh.
Well, let's try it, right?
In the forest, right?
Corpaps.
You son of a bitch.
Okay.
And we're out of way!
Corpap, huh?
That's not four.
This four?
Can I jump on you?
Nevermind, it's fine.
Is this four?
Ah, you slurped me!
Oh, it's above ground, okay.
Ooh, level up!
That's so cool.
Hey, Mercy, what...
What mic do I use for gaming streams?
80-2020.
Four, right? Is this four?
Left.
Straight.
Straight?
Right?
Is this correct?
That's left, is that left?
Which way is right?
This right?
Senpai.
Senpai!
Wait, the wrong way.
Go straight here.
I think this was...
I think this was it.
Yeah, yeah, okay.
Left.
Two lefts, right?
This is one left.
Is this left over here?
No, no, no.
Left over here?
This is left.
Wait.
Wait, I confused myself.
Okay, somewhere you enter.
Okay, left.
Left.
Straight.
That's straight, right?
Right.
This is right, right?
Wait.
That's left. Wait, what?
This one?
Left.
Let this start over.
Reactions are hard.
Okay, ready?
Left.
Straight.
Right.
This one, right?
It's here!
Yeah!
We did it!
Yatta!
I may have been directly challenged.
I'm just gonna take the map now.
I'm just gonna take the map now and be like,
hey, I found it!
I'm sorry.
I'm on the treasure, way to go, keep up the good work.
I'm sorry I stole all of them.
Yeah, I jumped in it, I do it out of time,
it really winds my dad up.
This fucking brat.
All kids in this game, right?
I'm sorry.
Pipe vault.
What's the smallville?
Okay, let's go to this pipe vault.
Let's just exit out again.
Just exit out again.
Pipe vault.
Oh no.
Okay, let's just exit out again.
Thanks.
Whoa!
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha!
Blood. Bloodless.
Magic!
There's two pipes.
One's a lie!
Understood, one's a lie.
Right?
Wait.
Hm?
Otherwise, it be tiny.
Kasunpi!
How do I change the party leader?
Like this?
Well, I can't do anything about it.
Oh well.
Probably something to do later, whatever.
Oh hi!
Hey mate, stick right up.
I'm going to do some Goomba Thumpin'.
How about a minute?
I'll save it another day.
Damn!
Why is he so mad at me? Fine.
Know the rules?
Nope.
Thump a Goomba, get one point.
Stump a Spikey, lose a point.
Thump a Gold, Goomba, get three points.
Twenty points and more, get a prize.
Want to recap?
No thanks.
How do I do this?
Easier if you stand in the middle.
Like this?
Get as many as you can, alright?
Wait, like this?
Oh!
This is a little hard!
Hey.
Wait, can I go through all of them?
No, that was a lie.
That one's a lie.
That's real.
Real.
Kind of a bitch.
I thought I had the timing right.
When I said I thought I had the timing right, I thought I had the timing right.
What are these things?
Why are you just taking my money?
Fuck you.
My money.
Son of a bitch.
I'm about to start hurrying.
I was wondering what was happening and then I was...
Fuck this game, my money.
Don't start.
I don't know what the fuck is this place.
Yoshi!
There's nothing inside.
There's a letter and I care to read it?
Sure.
Honeymoon reservation for two.
Mushroom travel agency.
Mario, glad you made it to Yostar by a home of the Mushroom Derby.
Say, now that you're here, we can use your help.
Please talk to a few of my pals herein.
Oh, you can't understand them well.
I'll hop before and I'll be your interpreter.
Yoshi!
What are you all looking at?
You want to challenge me, you have to bring cookies.
It would be so much better if we could all race together.
Yoshi, you think you can meet the old bushy today?
Not now today.
That may mean other days, so you heard, right?
Just waiting for the day we can all race together.
Yoshi only races one on one, so everyone can't join us too bad.
Oh, she peers the fastest runner, but he falls on himself.
Why do you crack races in my life?
I could run a day, and I know when I saw not too long ago a star falling somewhere in your mobile.
I have to bring cookies.
Hey, there's a letter in here, but I can't read it.
Did I talk to everyone?
Fuck it, let's do it.
Yeah, let's do it.
Here, take my cookies.
Good luck, I'm rooting for you.
Thanks, I've got major support on my side, so I can probably win today.
Oh, she got some cookies.
You're going to beat Boshi, the yellow one.
This is Boshi.
Oh wait, honeymoon.
I love honey.
I want to go on a honeymoon with some pie.
Ah, so you brought yourself cookies, alright.
Consider yourself lucky today.
One on one.
So how do I do this?
Oh, again.
Oh, once again.
Get ready for the mushroom derbies coming up.
One instructions, yeah.
Guess A and B alternately with the rhythm.
Titer the rhythm, the faster you go.
Spy during the rate to eat a cookie.
Energy will help you go faster.
Okay, one instruction again.
I'll try, keep on aiming between A and B in time to the beat.
Let's practice.
One, two, one, two, one, two, three.
Uh.
I'm not getting it right at all.
Are you sure you want to do this?
I feel cold out.
I feel cold out!
Ahhhh!
What am I doing wrong?
Am I alternating the wrong way?
Okay, I'll try it again.
Ahhhh, we're doomed!
I could say screw and just race, I guess.
Fuck it.
Wait!
Wait, what's going on?
Wait.
Am I pressing the wrong buttons?
Oh, I'm pressing A and B, right?
Okay, now everyone has learned that I have no sense of rhythm.
Ahhhh!
I've been using a visual guide!
Okay.
Okay, one two,
one two, one two, three.
One, two, one two, one two, one two,
one two, one two, one two, one two, one two,
one-
Son of a bitch!
It's too fast!
Oh my gosh, I have no sense of rhythm!
I hate this! I hate this!
I hate this so much!
I hate this!
I'm gonna do it again!
I'm very stubborn!
I hate this!
Fuck you!
Oh! I did it!
Wow, unbelievable! You just before she!
Starting today, Yoshi's a new boss around here.
Since when have you been able to sprint like that?
Oh, I had my day in the sun. Let me give you a tip.
Race someone slow.
Oh, wait, you'll be able to stash away the cookies.
Oh, you don't need a boss! Anyway, I just want to race.
Come on, Poshi. Let's see what you're made of.
Alright, just stay out of my way. Here's the cookie stash for the winner.
Thank you, Mario. I finally got to beat that rascal.
Mario's together now.
Here's something to remember me by.
Awesome, Yoshi.
I'm in trouble during battles. Just one of these. Give me a call.
Wow, thank you, my stubborn.
Great. Also, yeah, actually, that instruction was horrible.
Haha.
Oh, cute animal!
I kinda went to the mountain with a little mic.
The star cached in the mountain, now they'd be trapped.
Pan coins for a night, y'all stay in the night.
It's like, pan coin for a night, y'all stay in the night now.
Come on in, don't be shy. Everyone up in the mountain, but I'm stuck mountain in the store.
So what you need?
Bye.
Mid mushroom.
Maple syrup.
Punch glove.
Symbols.
Your shot.
I already have that.
Mega shirt.
Ant.
Orc ants.
Take a cape.
Would these be any better?
Orc ants are pretty good at this point, you think so?
Should I give them a Gino, cause like, it goes up for everything.
It's an emergency, Diana's trapped in the mines.
I'm also getting pretty tired, some pie.
What is here?
It's because they're all trapped in the mine.
What do you start crashing down into the mountain?
I wanna see, but Ma told me it was too dangerous.
I said you go and find out what's happening, but she's sure taking her sweet time.
What am I even doing with these voices?
Bowser.
Most of our allies have rounded out, what do we do?
You only end experience finding Mario, these new guys are too much.
Shut up, all of you.
I'm the biggest baddest brute around, and don't you forget it.
Mario hears that I've been kicked out of my own castle.
My reputation will be ruined.
Even I have an image to keep up, you know?
Let him show him who's boss around here.
He's so cute.
Oh, he's so cute.
Star trapped in the mountain, trapped some kids inside.
Make things worse, one of the men folk be stuck inside too.
Please Mario, you gotta help us.
What's happening up there, is she working up a sweat?
And so are the men, everyone's digging and digging.
I keep up with them.
I knew it was bad news when the star fell in the mountain.
Fair enough it's causing trouble.
And folk are doing their best from the inside, I'm digging in from the outside.
Gotta help them folks out.
Alright.
Guess...
Am I helping?
From the inside?
Oh dear, I sure hope the kids are okay.
I know how you're feeling.
I know how you're feeling, but more around here ain't gonna help thing.
I know what I said, but I don't think I'll be feeling any different if I were her.
I'm getting nowhere fast, I'm gonna have to reach the kids at this rate.
Look at that thing, that's up there, their own entrance to mine.
Oh, we can't reach it anymore.
Only that fellow on Mario over here, he can reach that in heartbeat.
What?
Well, speak of the devil.
What are you doing?
I'll be a goomba's uncle if it ain't him in the flesh.
Mario, you're a life saver.
Mario, have you heard the news?
News, what news?
Oh, Don took her little bro, they're into the mine so they can play.
And then a huge star crashed into the mountain causing a big cave, and now they're trapped inside.
Now their daddy who's looking for him is trapped too.
Mario, will you help rescue them?
Of course.
Thanks Mario, well the entrance is up there.
Well, help on our shoulders.
Yeah, we got it.
Imagine me saying no.
I feel like I'm in the wrong game.
I'm pretty sure these are star me's.
Bye bye.
Thank you for the $10 super chat.
It's not so daijuu, don't mind the voice, they're adorable.
Love.
Also, here's a bit more for the moving fun.
Thank you so much.
They totally are star me's, right?
They're like, you know, um, legally distinct star me's.
Hahaha.
Lucky.
Can I do triple move?
What?
What the fuck?
I can't believe the power of friendship did not work on rock.
Double your EXP, challenge the system.
Win big or lose it all.
Sure?
Where's Yoshi?
Fuck!
It's okay.
Hey, why is there a guy here?
Have you heard?
There's a rare item hidden in the mines.
I mean, I'm gonna sell them to someone in town.
I'm getting it for the money.
Get up here!
Oh shit, Malo's down.
It's like Malo's always down.
Oh, what's Gino?
Maybe some more defense?
You not, I remember you knocked down a little too much.
Over here.
Okay.
Errol's planting.
I'm so tired.
Ow.
I knocked down!
I'm so tired.
Coins, coins, beautiful coins.
Grab the coins.
That's enough.
Let's leave this half-way to Mario here and split.
Anyone got beef with that?
There we go.
Croco got us again.
There are coins too.
Let's turn this thing down and get him back.
Not again.
Old boy looks like dead in here, but not to worry.
Yeah, kind of bomb.
Never leave home without him.
One of them.
Come on.
No!
My money.
Can you wait?
We'll get you for this.
Maybe not today, maybe not tomorrow, but someday.
Now, the coins on him, but he dropped the flower tab.
One, really?
Ah
It's just self-destructed
Listen here, little punk
You
Wait, you can't do this time. Maybe that's a some day
I hate this game so fucking much right now
You
I
Did they go
All right, are you coming to help us one problem though this is dead end a bomb blast through here think you can find one
I
Find I need to find the guy
Fuck is he
I
Where's the croc man
Awesome
And pie I lost them
I
Lost them wait
Where they went
Now it's my bad
Oh my god, oh my god
I
Hate this game right now. I think I'm so tired as well that I'm losing
I'm losing my touch. I mean like not that I had it in the first place, but it's worse than you
I
Are
It was just there
I have to just wait there just ambush him
Gotcha
I
This better work
It's better fucking work
Come on friendship
Oh
Are you still for me on the back take me down first
All my inventory stuff is gone
Oh
How many how many how does this motherfucker have
Yeah, it's enough already you're gonna junk
Man here wait give me my money back to
Oh
Got the coins back it picks up a micro bomb too
Well, oops, I didn't mean to take a cap shit
Oh
Fuck
Okay, let's get it in here got a bomb now a bus through in no time
Alrighty stand back how handy of him to own a micro one
Let's track follow the tracks to the end what the star is probably in the back it smells you along now
Oh, guess you're right
I'll just be a burden on you fellas on that account on you had to find the kids here
Well, thanks a lot Mario because I'll be going back to tell mom about everything
Oh, I can go up there
Oh wait
Treasure
Oh
Okay saving here might be it okay saving here might be at some pie
I think it's I think that's it
I
Think that's it for today. I'm sure some pies are like wow our coal highs kind of
Pie
Oh, no
It's gonna replay all of the notifications, isn't it?
I'm gonna replay all the notifications. No
Oh
Oh my god, it's okay. It's okay. Okay
Dang it
It's okay, let's go over
Let's go over
This week's schedule
Tomorrow I have an Among Us collab with Yume plus
All of us are
are
Gonna gonna try to kill each other I guess
Um followed by followed by Wednesday. It's death mark again
And then on Friday we have a member's only stream
Or smt nocturne
So I get to to talk more about games and the smt universe and maybe we can research more about the the the demons
Senpai we'll talk more about the demons and stuff. So I think it will be really fun
Senpai so yeah, we'll see we'll see how it is. I mean like
It will be my first member's stream. So I hope I can make it
Memberable
I
Crack myself up
Oh
Okay, I'm sorry about the senpai things kind of keep going for a while. So yeah, that's
That is
That's it for this uh stream for today
Um, I'll probably go back to this game, but I want to finish um harvester
Na
Next week maybe yes, and we'll see what other games there there are now
How is the slower schedule been easier on you? Yes. Yes. Yes. It's been quite
Um easier and I have more time to do outside work
um, that's aside from um screening
So I get to catch up on work that I've been meaning to catch up on uh, that's
that's uh
Like a lot of audio a lot of audio stuff and also catching up on chores that that I should have been doing
But I've been so busy
So
But yeah, I'm hoping to to ramp it up a little later. Maybe
More relaxing too. Yeah, I need like
Sometimes my days off aren't really days off. They are days to work on other things
I hope that makes sense. It's like
Maybe of the three days I have off
So
One of them is a real day off
So, yeah, I think
It's just non-streaming stuff. Yeah
Oh, it's free. Wow, we're free somehow. Oh, I thought it would go long on for for longer
Oh
Yeah, so
Ah
I thought it would be until you ended stream. Yeah, I thought it would be until I end the stream too
but uh, luckily right now
we're in the low and
And it it stopped I'm surprised honestly legitimately surprised. So hopefully this week is uh
Is it's gonna calm down is a little bit of a slow down calm down. It's funny because um
Um
I was only gonna have three streams this week and then and then
Umid plus was like do you want to play among us and I said
Yeah
So that's what happened that's what happened
That's what happened. I was like, uh
Actually, yeah
Amugas
Uh, so among us is that um a different time. So it's at
Instead of my regular 11 p.m. EDT
It's going to be at 8 p.m. EDT instead. So I hope some pies can catch that tomato
So be an earlier stream. So we'll probably end up
end earlier
as well and usually
Um, it's not that I don't like them, but usually social gatherings are very exhausting, right?
Tomario, thank you
8 p.m. EDT. Yes
Mm-hmm
So, yeah, I hope my supplies have a good one I am so excited since
Since it's uh
Since I get to I get to hang with the guardrails
but also
I get to to spend more time with you my plus you my plus has been so kind
Kind and they're really nice girls. So yeah, let's see who's on see if we can raid someone
And then I'll let you all go for today
Oh shit, nobody's on
So you're gonna have to face the silence with me at the end. Okay, senpai
I followed so many vtubers and nobody's on
Oh
Oh rather I subscribed
No, the curse of late night streaming. Yeah
so
Senpai, thank you so much for joining me today. I hope you enjoyed
Uh mario rbg even though I was bad at it
I'm not I don't call myself a gamer
But sometimes I'd be gaming
So
I'll send you guys off
Remember
Screen information. Yeah
Bye-bye
You